there's a new bar in Washington DC
themed after a very special old friend
hit Samia Mario and I'm an alcoholic oh
thank you oh thank you
but Mockingbird Hill is celebrating
cherry blossom season and the most
logical way possible by turning itself
into a pop-up bar about a pixelated
Italian plumber the bartender is like I
finally have a reason for this dumb
hipster mustache finally and I'm glad I
bought all those shake weights the bar
is open until April 15th and you can get
all sorts of Mario themed up in there
like a drink called what doesn't kill
you makes you smaller and you can
usually buy some mushrooms from a guy in
the bathroom there is even seating
reserved for King Koopa but Steve Madden
like to sit there because it's close to
the winds bathroom comedians I want I
want you to tell the bartender your
problems at the Mario bar then this I'm
gonna go to the pac-man bar and drink
until my ghosts catch up to me yes
points
very good very good I have antenna this
must be a Mario bar because I'm getting
super smashed brother yeah
very precious see you drink like this -
if your evil cousin Wario was up in your
wife why don't we get taping the whole
thing the whole thing what a gorilla
jerk-off on a ladder
come here why so nice to me
it's less creepy if it's in an offensive
Italian it's one way I want to hear you
breathe let me sleep at night a turtle
on its feet
I can see right up into the your you
picking the wrong rest up flowing
through you don't see your friends and
family forever now I thought the glory
hole was a world war
Oh